fast food chain panda express is
introducing a new plant-based
version of their most popular entree
today rich tomorrow takes a taste test
in today's tech smart plant-based foods
continue to get more popular and now
panda
express is getting on board they're
teaming up with beyond me
for a plant-based version of their
popular orange chicken
so how does it taste let's find out
at panda express orange chicken is the
most popular
item on the menu it's about a third of
our business
close to about 100 million pounds we
sold last year the crispy fried chicken
tossed in a tangy sweet sauce
keeps customers coming back
now a new choice a plant-based version
called
beyond orange chicken we definitely had
to taste and taste and taste
for the past year we have many many
iterations
but at this point we believe this is the
best product we want to showcase our
restaurant the company teaming up with
beyond meat for the test item
one thing i notice about it is that the
nuggets are pretty uniform
they all kind of look the same it's a
nice bite sized nugget
beyond meat might best be known for
their burgers at hq
over 200 scientists and food
technologists
break down animal meat to a molecular
level in an attempt to recreate the
taste
and texture while improving on nutrition
this is a necessity you know
with all the global warming and all the
environmental issues that we have
we have to have a more sustainable
solution for our food
now with a panda partnership and new
tenders rolling out to other restaurants
nationwide
beyond is planting itself in the chicken
wars our target is meat eater this is
for everybody
it's not just for a small percentage of
population
you know and again they will be the
judge so it's just cooked up fresh so
let's give it a taste looks crispy on
the outside it's got that nice
glaze as well and here we go
the flavor is right there the
consistency is there the crunch is there
hard to believe this chicken is mostly
made from fava beans
and peas i think if you didn't tell
someone this is not
actual chicken they would not know it's
all very convincing
beyond orange chicken is a remarkably
realistic recreation of the original and
although it's not health food
it does improve on the nutrition just a
bit select panda express locations in
new york and los angeles are now serving
it
if you want a list just go to my website
it is rich on tech dot tv
i'm rich demero and you are tech smart